[Musik]
tatort deutschland die kranken von bild
an ihr verschwand da hatte ich schon so
ein komisches gefühl im bauch tanja das
dauert lange bis ich dich wiedersehen 20
bis 30 jahre wenn überhaupt diese
intuition die hatte ich sofort die
vorahnung einer mutter und sie sollte
recht behalten mein name ist ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen folge von tatort
deutschland heute beschäftigt uns ein
vermisstenfall ein cold case der bis
heute nicht geklärt ist und 1998 in
wuppertal seiner rätselhaften anfang
nahm
1998 tanja mühling aus ist eine hübsche
teenagerin und das ist sie wirklich ein
jungen schwarm wie er in der bravo
stehen könnte und das tat sie
tatsächlich später auch aber leider
unter traurigen vorzeichen die 15
jährige jedenfalls geht auf ein
gymnasium in wuppertal sie ist ein
sportliches mädchen fährt gerne ski und
träumt davon eines tages tänzerin zu
werden seit einigen wochen hat die
15-jährige damals einen festen freund am
21 oktober
1998 einem mittwoch soll sie eigentlich
ganz normal zur schule gehen aber sie
verlässt dass eltern aus und
verschwindet spurlos
frank schneider ist ende der 90er schon
bei der bild- und ist es als
chefreporter bis heute
tanjas fall ist ihm gut im gedächtnis
geblieben die bild zeitung berichtet
damals ausführlich über das verschwinden
wir sind hier in wuppertal und hier
verschwand tanja mühling haus damals war
ich junger reporter und habe diesen fall
damals schon verfolgt man hört dass
immer spurlos verschwinden aber man kann
es sich nicht vorstellen ist erhältlich
der tag sie ging zur bushaltestelle und
plötzlich war sie einfach weg die ersten
fragen die sich in so einer situation
stellen sind ist anja ausgerissen wo sie
entführt oder getötet
fragen die ihre mutter seit 23 jahren
quälen tanjas vater ist mittlerweile
verstorben und hat seine tochter nie
wieder gesehen
alexander kresta erster
polizeihauptkommissar hat die akten nun
weniger beweisstücke zum fall tanja
mühling haus in sein büro kommen lassen
mit reporter frank schneider will er
sich die fakten der ermittlung noch
einmal vor augen führen was hat es mit
zwei mysteriösen briefen auf sich die
wenige tage nach tanjas verschwinden
ohne absender auftauchen stammen sie
wirklich von ihr und welche rolle spielt
eigentlich der verurteilte straftäter
patrick der nach jahren plötzlich bei
der polizei aus sagt er kenne tanja
stimmen seine angaben
weder mit lasso seinem fall der in ganz
besonders geprägt hat das leid die
trauer die ungewissheit da kann man auch
nicht einfach abschalten und auch als
mittler fragt man sich habe ich
vielleicht irgendwann mal eine spur
übersehen oder
falsch bewertet frank schneider kreist
mit dem finger eine kleine reihenhaus
siedlung auf der karte von wuppertal ein
hier in wuppertal oberbarmen wohnte
damals tanja mühling haus mit ihren
eltern und auf dieser straße ging sie
morgens kurz nach halb neun zur schule
was dann wirklich genau passierte weiß
keiner sicher ist nur sie telefonierte
noch mit ihrer mutter aus dem haus und
80 31 das ist doch gleichzeitig das
letzte direkte lebenszeichen von tanja
nur 300 meter läuft die 15 jährige von
ihrem zuhause im hölken nummer 18 bis
zur bushaltestelle rottenstein der bus
fährt dann nur einige minuten bis zum
drei kilometer entfernten carl duisberg
gymnasium
ob sie sich aber überhaupt auf ihrem
normalen schulweg gemacht hat bleibt
ungeklärt klar ist nur sie ist dort nie
angekommen wir haben auch keinen
einzigen zeugen gefunden der
letztendlich tanja auf dem schulweg oder
in bus oder noch im bereich der schule
gesehen hat also eigentlich verliert
sich die spur
spätestens im alter land zuerst denken
die ermittler tanja könne ausgerissen
seien nichts ungewöhnliches bei
jugendlichen in dem alter aber tanja ist
ein fröhliches und villen starkes
mädchen obwohl in der pubertät ist sie
immer verlässlich und hat kaum stress
mit ihren eltern warum sollte sie
ausreisen
ermittler alexander christa streicht
sich über die grauen stoppelhaare und
tippt mit dem bleistift auf die
tischplatte man hat natürlich auch
mutmaßen dass tanja vielleicht zunächst
frei nicht mit jemanden bekannten
mitgegangen ist oder als tanja von
vornherein gleicht einem kapitaldelikt
zum opfer gefallen ist die polizei nimmt
die vermisstenanzeige auf ein
routinevorgang dass teenager mal
fortlaufend passiert wie erwähnt häufig
dass sie verschwunden bleiben ist aber
selten im ersten angriff war dieser fall
jetzt sag ich mal nichts besonderes mehr
als 1000 vermisstenfälle damals in der
kreispolizeibehörde wuppertal gehabt
davon sind natürlich nein ich viel strom
tanja war einer der fälle und man sagt
okay ist aus dem elternhaus abgeholt
mehr davon ausgehen dass sie sich selber
entfernt hat und wenn sind tatsächlich
auch davon ausgegangen dass sie nach
kurzer zeit wieder nach hause zurück
tanja ist also einfach so losgelaufen
ohne geld kleidung oder papiere
unwahrscheinlich wurde sie entführt
frank schneider besucht die mutter von
tanja elisabeth kronauer die seit mehr
als zwei jahrzehnten wartet dass ihre
tochter zurückkehrt die frau mit der
starken brille und dem lockenkopf
erinnert sich an die ersten minuten nach
dem verschwinden der teenagerin während
sie nervös den blumenstrauß neben tanz
porträt sortiert
[Musik]
noch am selben abend gehen die eltern
zur polizei
gesehen hat zwei tage später scheint es
eine erklärung für ihr verschwinden zu
geben ein handgeschriebener brief von
tanja taucht auf ohne absender den
eltern fällt ein stein vom herzen die
polizei fühlt sich in der ausreißer
theorie bestätigt im ersten brief hat
sie geschrieben liebe mama lieber papa
macht euch keine zu großen sorgen ich
bin gesund und werde in zwei bis drei
wochen wieder zu hause sein deshalb
braucht ihr mich nichts zu suchen
kümmert euch bitte um die hasen und um
das babysitten verhaltet bitte die
sachen die ich bestellt habe lasst euch
für die zeit was für die schule
einfallen ich brauche ein bisschen
abstand und werde mich nächste woche
noch einmal melden eure tanja die erste
resonanz war gottseidank sie lebt ist
also nicht irgendwo
tod ins auto gezerrt worden oder so
das war erstmal eine erleichterung
drei tage später schrieb sie dann ihr
braucht euch immer noch immer keine
sorgen zu machen mir geht es gut und ich
werde nun doch schon am nächsten
wochenende nach hause kommen deshalb
braucht er mich nicht suchen ich hoffe
ihr habt oder werde die sachen erledigen
um die ich euch im letzten brief gebeten
habe
ermittler alexander christa holt die
briefe die auf dünnen papier geschrieben
in klarsichtfolie verpackt sind aus dem
aktenordner und reicht sie von schneider
die briefe sind
eins der zentralen thema sicher zu haben
weil die briefe sich von vielen vielen
anderen vermisstenfällen natürlich
unterscheiden sind das wirklich noch die
ori das sind die originalbriefe hier
erkennt man auch tatsächlich dass sie
einmal spurentechnisch behandelt worden
sind und tatsächlich tanjas dna wird auf
den briefumschlägen nachgewiesen und
auch ein schrift vergleich ergibt die
briefe kommen von ihr ja auch wenn uns
jetzt hier sieht das ist ja sehr
identisch auch die unterschrift wenn man
sieht eure tanja das sieht man ja
eigentlich schon dass es an einer
derselben person beschrieben wurden ja
genau was man nicht so 100 prozent
bewerten kann was euch da auch mal
formuliert worden ist es sind diese
briefe unter druck geschrieben worden
andere briefe die sie schreibt schreibt
sie tatsächlich viel ausführlicher nicht
in kurzen sätzen sondern in langen
schachtelsätzen mit anderen vokabular
wurde die 15 jährige gezwungen die
briefe zu schreiben wollte ein möglicher
täter zeit gewinnen und tanja im guten
glauben auf ein entkommen lassen als sie
briefe
auf und auch die eltern sagten naja wir
glauben schon dass wir jetzt wieder
kommen wir haben das auch vermutet wir
haben zwar nicht an und so maßnahmen
eingestellt aber natürlich ist das
ermittlungs niveau zu diesem zeitpunkt
dann etwas versuchen
[Musik]
doch als das wochenende von tanjas
angekündigte rückkehr kommt wartet
mutter elisabeth vergebens tränen stehen
in ihren augen und sie presst das
porträt von tanja an ihre brust ich hab
den ganzen tag die haustür hypnotisiert
weil wir eben gerechnet hatten dass sie
kommt als täter nicht kam da haben wir
dann noch mal die ganze maschinerie
angeworfen mutter elisabeth wendet sich
in ihrer verzweiflung an die medien
print tv egal hauptsache die menschen
halten die augen offen sind derzeit auch
wirklich jedes format recht jeder sender
wir können dieses bild in die kamera
zeigen wir wollten damit das so viel wie
möglich aufmerksam werden und vielleicht
als ja doch ein jahr gesehen die
gymnasiastin ist jetzt seit mehr als
zwei wochen verschwunden einige zeugen
melden sich wollen sie im kölner
rotlichtmilieu gesehen haben alexander
quester der mittler von damals schüttelt
leicht den kopf bei vermissten sachen
wird generell das rotlicht milieu so
nennen wollen immer gern ins feld
geführt wenn man sagt wenn sich personen
aus dem lebensumfeld entfernt haben sind
geldmittel nötig da muss man mal sagen
es ist ein extremes risiko eine 15
jährige die aus einem behüteten
elternhaus kommt in irgendeiner art und
weise in diesem bereich anzubieten und
da sind mir jetzt nicht gerade viele
fälle bekannt
nach den beiden briefen verstummt anja
für immer sie bleibt vermisst und die
eltern leben täglich mit dieser bürde
dann aber 2014 nach 16 jahren meldet
sich ein gewisser patrick o bei der
polizei und behauptet tanja zu kennen
deren sich freundliche mann mit den
unsteten augen gewinnt erst einmal das
vertrauen der mutter elisabeth krone
erst behauptet er noch dass die
schülerin ermordet wurde überlegte sich
und erzählt dann von einem gemeinsamen
kind dann gibt er eben an tanja aus
einer drückerkolonne zu kennen kurz zur
erklärung drücke sind menschen die an
haustüren und oft mittels nötigung
überteuerte produkte verkaufen oder
spenden einwerben ein gnadenloses
geschäft oft von kriminellen banden
organisiert
dramatisch klingt zumindest der hinweis
er werde mit tanja in einer
drückerkolonne gewesen und dann hätte
man beide zwangsweise in anwalt geführt
und in diesem wald anja angeschossen
oder her chancen natürlich ausführlich
nach spuren gesucht obwohl wir diesen
hinweis von anfang an nicht ernst
genommen haben die hinweise von patrick
o führen die ermittler in ein
abgelegenes waldstück
hier soll tanya noch schlimmeres
passiert sein frank schneider gibt
fragen die händen hätten dieser hinweis
gestimmt was hätte man denn finden
müssen naja das fängt schon mal an damit
dass man auf diesem engen begrenzten uns
beschriebenen waldstück hätte
zerbrochene stücke finden müssen aber
natürlich auch irgendwie spurenträger wo
vielleicht eine dna von tanja zu finden
gewesen wäre jetzt eigentlich aber auch
blut oder spuren wo gegraben ist all
diese
dinge haben wir nicht gefunden also es
hat sich in den kennzahlen und weise von
einer objektiven lage bestätigt dass ein
solches szenarium wald stattgefunden die
spur wird fallen gelassen patrick taucht
ab meldet sich aber 2017 drei jahre
später wieder diesmal aus der jva
wolfenbüttel wo er wegen betruges und
schwerer körperverletzung sitzt nicht
gerade ein zeichen von glaubwürdigkeit
und dennoch die verzweifelte mutter
elisabeth kronauer lässt sich auf ein
treffen mit ihm ein das von einem
tv-sender begleitet wird patrick macht
ein unglaubliches geständnis tanja aber
den schuss überlebt ein gemeinsames kind
mit ihm und wohne unter neuem namen in
frankfurt er will einen kontakt
herstellen
[Musik]
ja hab ich auch
damit positiv gelaufen
[Musik]
aber der tag des wiedersehens kommt
nicht elisabeth wird erneut enttäuscht
sie wird opfer eines betrügers denn
patrick hat sich alles ausgedacht dass
angehörige von betrügern kontaktiert
werden ist bei vermisstenfällen leider
keine seltenheit letztendlich wollen sie
sich ja an diesen strohhalm der
möglicherweise die lösung dass die
wiederkehr des kindes bewirken wollen
sie sich auch klammern und dass es dann
auch für uns als polizei immer sehr sehr
schwierig zu händeln bei manchen sachen
das ist einfach quatsch stadt sind
hirngespinste
und auch gegen solche leute das muss
mehr sein als polizei gehen wir dann
aber auch strafrechtlich vor die ganzen
brief für die hin und her gegangen sind
die habe ich alle auffahrt aber die sind
jetzt nicht sichtbar in meinem keller
gut verstaut weil ich die nie wieder
sehen will eine spur ins nichts tanja
mühling haus bleibt verschollen sie wird
zum cold case aber wo ist die 15-jährige
geblieben wie kann ein teenager spurlos
verschwinden lebt sie vielleicht noch
heute sucht mord ermittler markus
lindner nach neuen ansätzen er hat den
fall von alexander kresta übernommen und
gibt nicht so einfach auf uns gold sich
durch die digitalisierten akten seine
wachen blauen augen funkeln er hat noch
hoffnung wir suchen parallelen zu
möglicherweise anderen vermisstenfällen
im preis von nordrhein-westfalen aber
auch über nordrhein westfalen hinaus wir
gucken nach verurteilten täter nach
sexualtätern nach tätern von
tötungsdelikten wir versuchen da einen
vergleich zu finden oder möglicherweise
eine ähnlichkeit die damals mit tanja
mühlhaus übereinstimmt auch bild
reporter frank schneider und die mutter
von thalia bleiben dabei nicht aufgeben
ich würde mir wünschen noch mal über den
fall eine million horst zu berichten
aber ganz anders als bisher nämlich dass
es mir gut geht das erlebt dass ich im
idealfall ihr gegenüber sitzt und sie
fragen kann warum sie verschwunden ist
was in der zeit passiert ist und
vielleicht sogar mit ansehen durfte dass
sie ihre mutter wieder in die arme nimmt
oder die mutter sie tanja ist in jedem
tag in meinen gedanken präsent ich
vermisse sie genauso wie vor 23 jahren
das gefühl dass sie lebt das kann man
eigentlich nicht beschreiben das ist
einfach da aber ich habe nicht das
gefühl dass sie tot ist vielleicht gibt
es ja tatsächlich noch eine chance auf
ein wiedersehen von mutter und tochter
bleibt bitte bis zum schluss dran es
gibt noch wichtige informationen
bis zum nächsten mal euskadi
liebe kann ja wenn du mich hörst ich
würde mich unwahrscheinlich freuen wenn
wir uns zwar nochmals zusammen sprechen
könnten bitte melde dich doch du
brauchst dich für mich zu schämen
die wuppertaler polizei bittet die
bevölkerung um hinweise wem ist etwas
aufgefallen an tanjas wohnung im rücken
nummer 18 oder auf ihrem weg zur
haltestelle ottenstein in wuppertal
wer hat sie auf dem weg zu ihrer schule
beobachtet wer hat sie im kölner
rotlicht-milieu erkannt wer hat die 15
jährige tanja gesehen sie trug eine
dunkle jeans und eine schwarze
lederjacke die ermittler die familie und
die bild-redaktion sie alle geben nicht
auf wollen endlich gewissheit
[Musik]
tatort deutschland ist eine produktion
aus dem wakeboard studios
projektleitung simone terbrack
produktion fabian schaeffler drehbuch
lutz neumann
redaktion bild frank schneider stefan
netzeband